au Parlement polonais une minute de
silence en hommage aux deux personnes
tuées mardi par un missile sur le sol
polonais
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquête
mené par la Pologne et l'OTAN cette
frappe serait due à un tir de missile de
la défense entière aérienne ukrainienne
une thèse accrédité aussi par les
États-Unis
nous n'avons rien vu qui contredisent
l'évaluation préliminaire du président
Douda selon laquelle cette explosion
était très probablement le résultat d'un
missile de défense aérienne ukrainien
qui a malheureusement atterri en Pologne
et quel que soit les conclusions finales
le monde sait que la Russie est au bout
du compte responsable de cet incident
un tel scénario a fait peu à peu retombé
la pression mercredi alors que
l'hypothèse d'une frappe russe sur un
État membre de l'OTAN faisait craindre
une escalade majeure du conflit mais les
autorités ukrainiennes démontent tout
implication et continue d'accuser Moscou
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que
c'était pas notre missile ni notre
frappe de missile je n'ai aucune raison
de douter nous avons fait la guerre
ensemble
une position critiquée par certains
États notamment la Hongrie qui regrette
la rapidité des accusations ukrainiennes
contre la Russie dans une telle
situation les dirigeants mondiaux
s'expriment de manière responsable le
président ukrainien en accusant
immédiatement les Russes à eu tort c'est
un mauvais exemple
l'Ukraine réclame un accès immédiat au
point de chute du missile pour
participer aux investigations mais pour
l'heure la Pologne n'a pas donné son feu
vert
spoon il s'agit désormais d'une
procédure commune menée par des experts
polonais et américains experto vim et si
quelqu'un devait être autorisé à
participer à cette procédure il faudrait
au moins l'accord des deux parties
de son côté la Russie nie toute
responsabilité et a convoqué
l'ambassadeur polonais pour dénoncer
selon ces termes une hystérie anti russe
en Pologne